Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
¿Qué pasaría si lo que hoy
doy por sentado mañana me abandona?
¿Y si mi carrera deja de ser necesaria
para el momento en el que me reciba?
¿Y si mañana me gustan las chicas?
¿Y si tengo que cambiar lo que
creo para encajar en un grupo
o conseguir un trabajo?
¿Y si directamente no encajo?
Tengo miedo. Mucho miedo.
A veces ese miedo me genera angustia.
Otras veces me pide a gritos
que lo hable con amigos
e, incluso, que lo mantenga oculto.
Y a veces me paraliza.
El miedo viene de la mano
de la realidad en la que vivo
junto con otros adolescentes.
Creo que somos una generación
a la que le inquieta todo.
Y, como tal, queremos actuar al respecto.
Somos la generación
que abrazó la diversidad,
naturalizó la homosexualidad
y que, incluso, protesta
contra el maltrato animal
a través de su alimentación.
Pero si bien pareciera que estamos
dispuestos a hacerle frente a todo,
eso no significa que no tengamos miedo.
Son miedos potenciados
por la inestabilidad
de los cambios a nivel global
en materia económica
así como también en materia política,
social e incluso tecnológica.
No sé qué voy a hacer mañana.
Antes no sabemos qué vamos
a hacer dentro de unas horas.
Y mucho menos qué va a pasar mañana.
Quizás es un día normal.
O quizás es uno de esos en los que salen
seis nuevos modelos de celulares,
se desploman las bolsas del mundo,
salen tres nuevas redes sociales
con los mismos filtros de perrito,
o suceden atentados terroristas en centros
de ciudades como París o Barcelona
que dejan a decenas de muertos.
Hoy me paro aquí con 19 años
y toda mi vida por delante
y de lo único que estoy segura
es que me llamo Chiara.
Aunque quizás mañana me llame Pedro.
Hoy me compro ropa y para cuando
salí del local ya hay otra tendencia.
Hoy aprendo algo y mañana
no me sirve para nada.
Y es ahí donde me cae la ficha.
Donde me doy cuenta de lo alejada
que estoy de quienes me antecedieron.
Porque cambios existieron siempre
pero, hoy, no hay sistema aplicable.
No hay un consejo que seguir,
una receta que aplicar,
o un consejo que nos permita
alcanzar nuestros objetivos.
O, mínimamente, hacer frente
a todo aquello que debemos afrontar.
No sé cómo voy a vivir mañana.
Y mucho menos cómo voy a vivir
de acá a 10 años.
No sé si la inteligencia artificial
va a reemplazar a mi carrera.
No sé si vamos a comprar casas
o si vamos a vivir
en conventillos inteligentes,
o adentro de nuestros autos eléctricos.
Incluso no sé si voy a tener
una familia propia.
Se siente ilógico buscar permanencia
en un mundo tan cambiante.
Y no sé bien qué hacer.
Pero creo que lo único que me va a ayudar
a salir es adaptarme al cambio.
Adaptarme, abrazarlo
y animarme a proyectarme.
Es por eso que cuando pienso
en mi proyecto de vida
ya no pienso en hitos fijos
a cumplir a lo largo del tiempo,
sino en tres principios que creo
que se van a mantener estables
incluso cuando todo lo demás cambie.
Primero, ser la mejor versión
de mí misma. Siempre.
Segundo, adueñarme de mi presente
y futuro inmediatos.
Por ejemplo, esta semana
quiero levantarme temprano;
ni bien suena el despertador,
para aprovechar el día.
O, este mes quiero aprobar mis parciales.
Y tercero, me voy a proponer
objetivos flexibles en el largo plazo.
Este personalmente es el principio
que más me cuesta
porque tengo una ligera tendencia
a buscar rigidez, o puntualidad.
Incluso cuando soy consciente de que
las cosas no se den como yo lo espero.
Es por eso que, por el momento,
mi mejor ejemplo de este principio
es el dedicarme a estudiar
solo lo que me motive.
Por el momento, me quiero recibir
en tiempo y forma.
Y lo veo posible, porque estoy
enamoradísima de la profesión que elegí.
Pero si en el medio del proceso
sufro un desencanto
quiero tener el valor
para cambiar de camino.
Porque tener miedo está bien,
es algo que a todos nos ha pasado
y que, a los adolescentes de los
próximos 10 años, también les va a pasar.
Que a mis hijos, si es que decido
tenerlos, también les va a pasar.
Creo que a esos hijos hipotéticos
voy a tener que darles todo
lo que yo necesito hoy.
Y eso no son fórmulas mágicas
o recetas que nos quedaron viejas.
Van a necesitar cariño.
Y que ese cariño sea una certeza
para la construcción de un futuro
que se muestra tan incierto.
Futuro que van a construir
en base a aciertos y errores
y a cambios propios de su adolescencia
que ellos también van a tener que
abrazar, así como hoy me toca a mí.
Porque eso es lo que yo necesito hoy.
Y estoy casi segura de que mañana también.
O quizás no.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)